Silicon Valley Bank may not be a
household name but in the tech sector it
is really important many Tech firms uh
bank with it both in the US but also in
the UK where it has an offshoot and that
is why this weekend we've had over a
hundred CEOs of tech firms in the UK
writing to the chancellor saying that
they believe this collapse represents an
existential threat to the tech sector
and could set back really the industry
by 20 years now the government appears
to be coming up with some kind of
solution some kind of cash Lifeline the
chancellor saying today that they've
been working hard speaking to the bank
of England over the weekend to make sure
that any UK Tech firms that are unable
to access cash that is tied up with
Silicon Valley Bank are still able to
get those cash flows that they need come
Monday morning Jeremy huntler also said
that he wanted to see a more longer term
solution that might look like another UK
bank potentially stepping in to buy up
the UK offshoot of Silicon Valley Bank
some kind of
um sort of rescue attempt and we
understand my colleague Mark Clement
understands this weekend that big High
Street lenders like Lloyds have even
been approached to consider this this
weekend although the likelihood of a big
lender like that stepping in seems low
the bank of London as well are also said
um to be interested I think politically
this matters because it's budget week
and also Jeremy Hunt and especially
Rishi sunak really have placed the tech
sector in the UK right at the heart of
their growth strategy so the fact that
they are looking at potentially cash
lifelines to help the industry it will
be an unwelcome development but I think
the fact that they have put Tech right
at the center of their approach for
growth moving forward is why they are
likely to be taking this very seriously
and trying to find some sort of solution
that works for the many firms that will
be very worried this weekend